est ce que dans sa tête gabrielle matte
emmanuel macron est sûr d'être réélu a
pas du tout pas du tout moi chaque fois
que je parle de l'élection
présidentielle avec le président chaque
fois qu ils nous en parlent ça arrive
pas très tard il me parle plus des
sujets ukraine et des sujets pouvoir
d'achat etc que de la question de
l'élection présidentielle mais quand ils
en parlent ce qu'ils disent et rien
n'est joué rien n'est fait et on a vu
dans l'histoire plein de gens vous
entendrez des gens dire alors c'est
dramatique de dire ça mais quand vous
entendez des gens dire la guerre en
ukraine a fait automatiquement réélire
emmanuel macron où vous dites quoi non
ce qu'on voit avec la situation en
ukraine c'est d'abord qu'elle est très
changeante qui est très évolutive moi je
sais pas vous dire ce qui va se passer
dans les semaines qui viennent donc
voilà rien n'est jamais fait dans une
élection ce qu'ils font les élections
c'est pas les sondeurs sont pas les
sondages c'est les français quand ils
vont voter est en fait jusqu'à ce que la
dernière une ordure dernier bureau de
vote de la dernière commune a été
dépouillée on sait pas qui est élu par
les français il a raison de faire aucun
débat le président avant le second tour
alors il fait des débats avec des
français il ya des débats avec des
journalistes des éditorialistes mais pas
avec les autres candidats pas jamais un
président sortant n'a fait de débat avec
les candidats au premier tour pourquoi
toujours pas question qu'il faut se
poser parce que imaginez-vous le ce que
c'est ce que à ce à quoi ça
ressemblerait vous avez l'égalité de
temps de parole c'est à dire tous les
candidats doivent avoir le même temps de
parole il ya douze candidats donc sur
deux heures d'émission vous auriez onze
candidats chercherait tous à avoir leurs
moments avec le président à
l'interpeller à lui poser des questions
président il n'a pas problème pas de
problème pour être interpellé pour
répondre aux questions mais au moins
faut qu'il ait le temps d'y répondre et
là il aurait dix minutes sur une heure
cinquante démission donc c'est le format
qui est pas possible c'est pour ça que
tous les présidents sortants ont fait le
choix alors ne pas faire ce genre de les
présidents sortants on a le dernier
président c'était françois hollande ne
s'est pas représenté ça me colle un
cercle a dit que sarkozy l'a passée
juste on se dit aussi la barre fois je
le dis dans cette émission je me mets à
la place d'emmanuel macron les sondages
ça vaut ce que ça vaut mais quand vous
avez 60 sondage qui vous donnent
largement en tête un moment on se dit
pourquoi je vais les prendre des risques
aux signes donc d'abord c'est pas sa
nature de se dire qu'il prend pas de
risque il prend des risques il a
toujours pris des risques il fait des
débats avec des français qui sont
retransmis à la télé il a fait des
émissions de télé il ya une émission sur
tf1 il ya deux semaines maintenant je
crois ou quasiment où il y avait tous
les candidats qui étaient invités là
pour le coup c'était le premier
président sortant qui se représente est
à faire une émission que faisaient les
autres candidats à participer au même
format la doctrine sinon c'était qu'il
fallait pas débattre au second tour
l'élection présidentielle si c'était
l'extrême droite on se souvient chirac
avait refusé sur fer est le premier à
avoir accepté en 2010 7,7 de débattre au
deuxième tour l'élection présidentielle
c'est face à la candidate de l'extrême
droite pensait qu'il y aura un match
retour je sais pas c'est les français
qui décideront en tout cas il débattra
avec marine le pen est candidat qui
c'est pas comme ça qu'on
réfléchisse il ya un moment on essaye de
convaincre les français parce que
tout le monde dit à chaque candidat
maintenant c'est devenu la mode chaque
candidat dit je suis le seul à pouvoir
battre emmanuel macron alors au départ
c'était valérie pécresse et elle disait
je suis la seule à pouvoir marc emmanuel
macron à panda vu eric zemmour il a dit
je suis le seul à pour abattre emmanuel
macron
marine le pen dit en ce moment je suis
la seule à pouvoir battre emmanuel
macron philippe poutou non
mais voilà donc c'est vrai que ça
devient un argument maintenant c'est fou
c'est toujours le même argument chez
tous les candidats mais il y en a bien
qui est plus dangereux que les autres
vins et les parfums qui passent leur
temps à parler d' emmanuel macron moi ça
me frappe dire tout le temps qui passe a
parlé du président ils pourraient le
passé a parlé des français de leurs
problèmes plutôt que de dire je suis le
seul à pouvoir battre emmanuel macron il
ferait mieux de dire je suis le seul à
pouvoir convaincre les français que je
peux retrouver du boulot que je peux
faire que le travail paye plus que je
peux les protéger et leur garantir la
sécurité en france non ils passent leur
temps à taper sur le président en est à
parler de stratégies politiques de
battre à intel et c'est nous c'est pour
ça que moi on veut parler aux français
pour parler de leurs problèmes des
solutions qu'on propose c'est ça notre
priorité
si vous devez
si vous deviez mettre une note au
quinquennat d'emmanuel macro survint un
volume étriqué comme je suis pas
objectif mais on salue m combien je suis
pas objectif je peux pas mettez vingt je
suis plus de parti pris moi j'aimerais
bien sûr mais même en étant de parti
pris c'est normal je dirais pas vain
parce que je considère pas que tout a
été réussi je considère pas qu'on a fait
tout ce qu'on aurait voulu faire je
considère pas qu'on n'ait pas fait
d'erreur on a fait des erreurs il ya des
trucs qui ont été rares des trucs qu'on
aurait aimé faire c'est quoi le truc qui
a été le plus craint tcc pouvoir entrer
dans le ce débat là mais on a fait des
erreurs voilà il ya des mesures qu'on a
prises qu'on n'aurait pas dû prendre par
exemple quand on a fait l'augmentation
de la taxe carbone sur l'essence en 2018
il ya eu le mouvement des rouges les
jaunes on aurait dû renoncer à ça je
pense que la manière dont on a décidé au
début les 80 kilomètres heure il aurait
fallu le faire avec plus de souplesse
pour laisser les territoires s'adapter
et faire les choses en fonction de la
réalité de chaque territoire voilà la
gestion du duc au vide sur la gestion de
covin oui il ya eu des erreurs aussi
mais comme dans tous les pays c'est un
bas moi j'ai pas d'exemple de pays qui
est gérée par fait dans cette crise elle
a surpris tout le monde personne n'était
pas vraiment préparé par définition
voilà et nous aussi forcément ça un peu
tâtonné on a fait des erreurs pendant la
crise faut l'assumer mais il ya aussi un
bon bilan on a le taux de chômage le
plus bas depuis 15 ans en france alors
quand les gens vous disent parce que
c'est ce que je dis je les lis dans la
fois j'ai pu j'ai dit à jean luc
mélenchon il m'a dit oui mais les
chiffres sont trafiqués voilà qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ça je réponds qu'il
faut interroger tous les français les
centaines de milliers de français qui a
retrouvé un boulot il faut interroger
les chefs d'entreprise moi je me déplace
beaucoup en france je rencontre des
artisans des commerçants des
restaurateurs qui me disent n'arrive pas
à recruter il faut regarder les chiffres
qui sont publiés par les économistes qui
montrent qu'il ya eu un million deux
cent mille emplois créés pendant ce
quinquennat c'est deux fois plus que
dans le quinquennat précédent donc c'est
ça la réalité qu'on constate sur le
terrain est d'ailleurs ce qu'on voit
c'est que dans cette élection
présidentielle la question du chômage de
masse est beaucoup moins présente
qu'elle l'était dans les précédentes
élections présidentielles alors là elle
a laissé sa place à d'autres débats
notamment le pouvoir d'achat le fait
d'être bien rémunéré pour son travail
mais quand même ce bilan sur l'emploi on
a le taux de chômage des jeunes le plus
bas depuis 40 ans on a réussi aussi la
réforme de l'apprentissage à
l'apprentissage c'est très bon pour les
jeunes parce qu'il se forme c'est bon
pour les entreprises il y avait sept
cent vingt mille jeunes en apprentissage
l'an dernier ils étaient moins de 300
milles quand emmanuel macron a été élu
donc a quand même un bilan que moi je
vous revendiquez que je mette en avant
même si encore une fois de leur voix
qu'il ya une frange de la population
voilà qui en veut énormément à emmanuel
macron voilà j'ai reçu des gilets jaunes
ici je reçois de nombreuses personnes
aussi qui en veulent énormément à
emmanuel macron est ce que vous arrivez
à savoir pourquoi qu'est ce qu'il ya
qu'est-ce qui a fait que
il a la voix dans les sondages il
caracole en tête mais il y avait
beaucoup de français qui lui en veulent
énormément pourquoi d'abord je pense
qu'il ya un côté inévitable quand vous
êtes président de la république que vous
êtes cinq ans au pouvoir en plus quand
vous êtes confrontés à des crises comme
celle là où c est françois hollande il
avait pas ça parce qu'on savait même pas
qui était président
il a eu la crise sanitaire il a eu la
crise des gilet jaune aujourd'hui à la
guerre en ukraine il ya eu des crises
par ailleurs il faut se rappeler aussi
dans quel contexte il a été élu il a été
élu dans un contexte où les extrêmes
étaient déjà très élevé le score de
marine le pen et de jean luc mélenchon
en 2017 ça fait quasiment 40% des
français donc il y avait déjà cessé
difficultés en france voilà maintenant
parce que j'essaye de faire quand je
rencontre des français qui ne s'oppose à
ce qu'on fait qu'ils sont pas d'accord
avec nous j'essaye de les convaincre en
répondant ligne gilet jaune par exemple
vous en avait parlé il ya un instant est
ce que vous auriez pas dû les recevoir
un peu plus en amont et les écouter
peut-être un peu plus tout de suite
peut-être que ça il y aurait pas eu ce
temps c'est bien pour le coût de ces dit
d'ailleurs alors je pense que peut-être
trop bas bleus manquent on aurait dû
plutôt prendre en compte ce qui
s'exprimait et renoncer à l'augmentation
de la taxe carbone oui ça c'est vraiment
moi je pense que ce qu'on a su faire
c'est d'abord mettre tout le monde
autour de la table entre guillemets pour
discuter on parlait tout à l'heure du
fait que le président du rapport du
président au débat c'est quand même lui
qui a fait le grand débat national on
n'avait jamais vu un président organiser
un tel exercice en france allait se
mettre au milieu des français dans
l'arène pour discuter avec eux pour
répondre à toutes les oppositions à
toutes les interpellations on a aussi
tenu compte dans les décisions qu'on a
prise d'accélérer sur beaucoup de choses
en augmentant la prime d'activité en
baissant les charges
une personne qui travaille au smic
aujourd'hui en france avec toutes ces
mesures elle a financé par l'état
l'équivalent d'un 13e et d'un quasi 14
années mais il ya aussi énormément de
gens et je le vois sur ce plateau qui
disent le 10 du mois on n'a déjà plus
rien et on arrive pas on est vraiment
pris à la gorge etc ça tous ces gens qui
en veulent à emmanuel macron selon moi
je les vois sur le plateau ce sont ces
gens qui se disent le 10 du mois ou n'en
énorme galère et est ce que ça vous
dérange quand tonique manuel maquereau
et le président des riches moi ça me
dérange que c'est pas la réalité
pourquoi se gardent les baisses d'impôts
qui ont été faites elles ont
principalement bénéficié pas en plus
riches mais plutôt aux classes moyennes
et à ceux qui travaillent dur et qui
n'arrivent pas à boucler leurs fins de
mois je dis pas qu'on a réglé tous leurs
problèmes il ya beaucoup de français qui
galèrent pour trouver alors vous avez
vous aidé aussi les entreprises allaient
ce que derrière les entreprises ont aidé
les salariés moi c'est le petit truc je
trouve wallace et je trouve que c'est
très bien vous ayez vraiment les
entreprises les grandes entreprises que
c'est important parce que ça crée de
l'emploi mais j'ai l'impression que
derrière c'est vrai que ça se
répercutaient pas sur les salariés voilà
qui qui voyait pas leur leur statut et
leur salaire augmenter ou changer
d'abord le fait d'avoir aidé les
entreprises notamment dans à baisser
leurs impôts
c'est ce qui a permis d'avoir le bilan
sur l'emploi et sur le chômage que
j'évoquais hier le fait qu'on ait fait
toutes les réformes qui étaient des
réformes difficiles au début du
quinquennat c'est pour ça que les
recrutements augmenté que les créations
d'emplois ont augmenté ensuite il ya une
grosse aide aux entreprises qu'on a fait
pendant la crise sanitaire c'est le quoi
qu'il en coûte et là on voit que ça a
bénéficié directement aux salariés
puisqu'ils ont pu garder leur emploi si
on l'avait pas fait il y aura eu des
minions licenciements en france
maintenant évidemment ce qu'on leur
demande c'est pour celles qui peuvent et
notamment dans les branches qui le
peuvent oulaï où il ya le plus de retard
d'augmenter les salaires et on a obtenu
un certain nombre d'accords dans
certains secteurs il ya eu un accord
dans le secteur de l'hôtellerie cafés
restauration il ya eu un accord dans le
secteur de la métallurgie dans le
secteur de la propreté faut aller plus
loin et dans le programme d' emmanuel
macron il ya des propositions pour aller
plus loin alors il ya par exemple la
prime macron il ya plus de 4 millions
entre cette année de salariés qui en ont
bénéficié qui est versée par les
employeurs et l'état en fait supprime
tout ce qui est chargé impôts sur cette
prime gars progressent de la tripler
c'est-à-dire qu'elles pourront verser 3
fois plus à leurs salariés on veut
développer ce qu'on appelle
l'intéressement et la participation dans
les entreprises d'ailleurs quand une
entreprise adb faut répartir la valeur
aussi avec les salariés on veut
supprimer un certain nombre de taxes qui
existe on avait déjà supprimé la taxe
d'habitation que les français paient en
moyenne à 1000 euros aux 1200 euros on
l'a supprimée pour 80% des français pour
les 20% restants elle sera
définitivement supprimé en 2023 là on
propose de supprimer la redevance télé
donc c'est un regain de 138 euros pour
tous les français qui l'appellent ils
sont très nombreux documents à leur tour
de la pub après 20h à soues france
télévisions ça c'est parce qu'on a
annoncé mais mais en tout cas on te
donnera à france télé et aux services
publics les moyens à voir évidemment
continuer à travailler on en dépendance
sûr il ya aussi beaucoup de gens qui
vous reprochent je vous dit tout voilà
ce qui revient souvent
la suppression de l'sf pour l'ifi impôts
voilà sur la fortune immobilière
sas et c'est là aussi c est ce à cause
de ça que vous taxent de président des
riches mais en fait on était dans une
situation en france on taxait beaucoup
plus que les autres et vous aviez donc
des personnes qui quittaient la france
pour payer moins d'impôts donc ce qu'on
a tout simplement fait c'est essayer de
rattraper un peu et de diminuer un peu
pour convaincre des personnes de rester
en france et d'investir en france si on
n'avait pas le bilan qu'on a eue sur la
baisse du chômage sur la création
d'activités économiques en france moi je
m'entendrai qu'on me fasse cette
critique mais le fait est que ça a quand
même fonctionné puisque on a encore une
fois un taux de chômage qui est au plus
bas depuis 15 ans et moi j'assume cette
réforme parce que ce qu'on a dit c'est
que il ya des personnes qui ont de
l'argent en france là des personnes qui
ont réussi en france nous ce qu'on veut
continuer à taxer c'est ce qu'on appelle
la fortune immobilière c'est à dire
l'argent entre guillemets qui dort
puisqu'il est dans l'immobilier et on
veut ne plus taxer l'argent qui sert à
investir dans les entreprises et dans
l'emploi en france vous avez des
candidats qui propose de faire l'
inverse marine le pen par exemple dans
son programme elle propose de supprimer
l'impôt sur la fortune immobilière ça
veut dire que les français qui ont
aujourd'hui une fortune immobilière au
dessus d'un million deux cent mille
euros elle veut supprimer les impôts sur
cette fortune immobilière élevé en
revanche taxer plutôt l'argent qui va
dans l'économie qui va dans
l'investissement dans les entreprises
moi je pense que ce serait inefficace
pour l'emploi se serait pas juste